hey clay  good to hear from a man hey listen you  only get to hang out with either me or  Alex and since you already hung out with  Alex technically you can't hang out with  me I'm just [ __ ] with you we can hang  out and I'll send you one of my cigars  just give me an address and and enjoy  that number one tequila and  and just keep on spreading the word  about that and you and I'll be friends  forever I doubt I'll do a show in Mathis  Texas anytime soon but I do go out to  corporates every once in a while and my  mother still lives in San Antonio so you  can you can bet I'll be at the Majestic  there thanks for being a fan and and I  appreciate you hanging out with my  brother  take care  you